hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast a keynote presentation
solid phase micro extraction new
developments in bioanalysis and medical
applications
it is presented by barbara boyco phd who
is an associate professor at nicholas
copernicus university in toround poland
and janusz pavlichen phd who is a
professor of chemistry at the university
of waterloo in ontario canada
i am judy o'rourke of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots
lab roots is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars
before i begin i'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen
our speakers will respond to your
questions via email
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
please join me in welcoming dr boiko and
dr pavlisian i will now turn the
presentation over to them
thank you very much for the kind
introduction
so i will be talking first my name is
janus pavlich from events
i said i was introduced
and in my part of my presentation i'll
focus on fundamentals just to give you
an idea why the technology works
and what the fundamentals of the
technology
so you when you look at this
presentation you have you need to have
open mind
because we'll be changing paradigm of
present way of doing anarcho-chemistry
there's specifically symbol preparation
now i will try to explain you something
which might be diffic looking difficult
to you
know in this key solid my first action
which we might not practice in every day
and it looks therefore difficult
but i will try to make it as simple as
possible don't
point out
the opportunity to improve the
understanding of the technology by
further
courses or
papers
so again the idea is to look out for the
books
what you do presently is not necessarily
the most optimal
the science moves forward and therefore
you need to consider your options
so the technology i hope i
focus on is in the area of sample
preparation
as you understand most of you are
practitioners on chemistry
so you understand that
this is the process that process
consists of several steps
so i will focus on the area of symbol
preparation so ideal symbol preparation
would facilitate
high throughput on vivo sampling
that's what the stm does
requires a very effective coupling
between the sampling symbol preparation
and convenient introduction to the
separation
device such as chromatograph or directly
master parameter
traditionally and many of you probably
consider symbol preparation as an art
not a science however the progress in
states allows us to look much more
carefully on different processes
occurring in when you do simple
preparation and therefore
you know you can actually have a full
understanding what you are doing so you
can rationally optimize
the process
to be very effective
and by doing so of course you have a lot
of advantages
i understand many of you are working in
clinical labs or industry won't have the
time to spend on it but of course i work
in academia i had opportunity to work
with the young scientists for
period of their thesis
we can make a scientific project
and therefore the depth of understanding
and by doing so we can make it as
interesting as possible so we can look
at the
subjects and leave them as you will see
we can look at the very difficult
samples
get a very interesting information about
the system
so uh basically the choice of your
central preparation which will allow you
to
drive the amount of information you are
going to
get and of course many of you
as i am are concerned about the
environment so
anytime you consider a new area of
sample preparation technology you need
to
consider the technology which are green
in nature which is eliminate organic
solvents
eliminate reagents
do measurement on site and individual
to facilitate measurements directly with
the samples so you don't need to
transpose a sample
to the laboratory which of course is
energy consuming instead so it's not
only elimination of solvent but also
moving
the
chemistry inside basically performing
the screening onsite analysis in some
cases like
medical laboratories is very important
because this gives immediate information
to the doctor
of surgeons about the condition of the
patient
now of course i'll be talking about
extraction so
i'll just remind you about the very
fundamental process process of
partitioning yes if you have a
uh for example sample making contact
with the extraction phase analyze
partition into the extraction phase if
you choose extraction phase
you have higher affinity towards the
underlying than the sample matrix so you
basically have this enrichment factor k
which is listed below
which is basically ratio of
concentrations at the
low concentration so you basically have
a process of increasing the
concentration or enrichment
so but without be focusing on it's not a
traditional exhaustive exercise
technique such as liquid liquid
extraction or protein precipitation
but i will try to encourage you to
consider micro extraction
so this would be very important for you
to understand the difference and the
advantages so this is the example
of to clearly demonstrate this
so here we have them
water analysis and so typically in water
analysis you have one liter of water
40 milliliters of solvent
and basically then you separate
this and do further
evaporation so you have a concentration
then you
when you concentrate to one milliliter
and then you inject one microliter out
of this into the ankle instrument
so it's a very very lengthy process uses
comparison of organic solvents
and of course evaporations and what's
happened with the
vapors of course it goes to the
atmosphere which eventually we breathe
so what i'm saying is let's replace it
with a much simpler process you have a
for example fiber coated with about one
microliter of the extraction phase and
type of solvent and place it in the same
amount of one liter water
now obviously some of you says well you
can do it but what about the sensitivity
of the measurements and in fact if you
go through the calculation
you'll find that the sensitivity will be
identical
and why
the reason why is by
trying to exhaustively extract using
40 liters of solvent
you actually lower the concentration in
water
and therefore
if you remember from the previous slide
when i show you distribution constant
the concentration water is less so
therefore the concentration
in the solvent is less as well why here
if you use a small amount of extraction
phase the concentration water doesn't
change so your
your
concentration on the fiber is much
higher so you have much higher
enrichment factor
so this is one advantage so you have
hydrism factor
and the other advantage is that
you don't need to define the volume
because if you do exhaustive extraction
you need to know the volume to know that
you're just exhausted extract right here
you basically place it in the source
we see we talk about tissue talk about
bloodstream we talk about
another application mind verification of
water and so on
so it's basically uh you don't need to
measure the volume of your sample which
is very convenient for on-site analysis
so
this is the major reasons why
microextraction
gaining
interest
so i would particularly focus on one
form of microextraction called solid
phase microextraction
and
this is the
technology where the extraction phase is
the sorbent
which is dispersed on some table support
and the amount of the solvent is low
so
as i discussed before you don't do
exhaustive extraction but you rather
extract
and calibrate the equilibria
or some kinetics
factors like it would be like a mission
below and flow field
flow injection analysis
the beauty about spme is not only what
they say is advantage of enrichment but
it's also you can code
any type of surface
yeah so you have a surface of the fibers
you can see surface of the tube surface
of the
vessels particles steering mechanism and
this can all of them has been already
investigated
you see the publication below which kind
of introduces to
those different topics quite early and
the previous slides you see the
references to
the
um to the books which has been published
on the topic so if somebody's interested
please
consider getting those books like in
this here you know you have another book
here in practice
so
if you use the fiber format which is the
most popular one and but it's not the
only one which we use
but most of the application will show
you here would be fiber but also the
blades i will show you in a moment
so basically you can consider three
different type of experiments direct
extraction yeah so if you have a
on the first slide
from the left no so you have a direct
extraction free matrix headspace
extraction which is very powerful
application of the spinning
or more recently and that's what i will
focus on looking at the very complex
samples and using some type of membrane
protection approach to avoid the
contamination of the coating by real
matrices
no they com
sdn is commercially available primary
for you looking at the food analysis in
fragrance type of um
compounds but also in clinical also
applications
residue for instance solid residues and
drugs
and uh
has been used in headspace of blood and
so on so it's a very complex matrix can
be analyzed that way because you isolate
the
sample from the extraction phase the
headspace
so
um the
device which is available is called
velco spme device
and uh is shown in here it's basically a
syringe where you have a coated fiber
inside the needle by moving the fiber in
and out
you can expose the fiber to the sample
or you can protect it in the needle now
so if you
extraction you expose the fiber
or if you look thermal dissociation it's
about the fiber if you penetrate the
scepter you
um keep the fiber in the
needle
and
typically automated the device is ctc
auto assembly which is sold all over the
world
this is another opportunity for you to
learn more the there was a recent paper
anchor chemistry
published in january this year
described describing the
recent developments of technology as you
can see in the center you see the
syringe and there are different
approaches including the drone you can
see underwater sampling doctor's office
vivo sampling we actually have the human
trials now so it's basically a lot of
different opportunities because
this technology facilitates that
so i will tell you now about looking at
the complex samples because we just will
be focused on our presentation so as i
mentioned to you the very popular
application of solutions micro
extraction is the headspace analysis as
you can see
in the headspace analysis you
separate
extraction phase from the complex
samples via headspace so anything which
which is volatiles goes to the fiber
coating and it's
enriched there
yeah you use the k value remember what
they discuss about then you can take it
out
and these orbital instruments and you
get a
good clean extract because anything
which goes through the headspace is
clean to be firmly dissolved in the
hot injector
of the gc and then separating the common
and detect it
so
what we have been working for last 20
years to develop this the rick
extraction
so you can see below we have fiber
placed directly in the matrix and we
wanted to also achieve this cleanup
approach so how did we do that
so you can see the matrix and the
compounds bound to the matrix they are
in the equilibrium with a free
concentration of the same analytes and
now we are trying to equilibrate the
coating
with
this free form so in fact anything which
goes the a3 form to the coating
as long as those matrix
doesn't
the matrix shown here that like proteins
or pieces of tissue do not absorb the
fiber you have a very clean extraction
as well because this goes vr34
this means this is reasonably soluble in
water so we can dissolve it in the lc
and uh
and see in director of
the solvent and then introduce it to the
lc and basically
perform the separations on the
clean matrix
so
here
the example would be benefit of that so
you have a apple homogenous
uh if you look on the left slide
and this is headspace
analysis 60 minutes extraction
and the
comprehensive dimension gas
chromatography
and you can see that compared to the
right
trace
where you have again two dimensional
chromatography compressed emission gas
chromatography
in way on vertical axis you have a
boiling point
and the on horizontal axis you have the
polarity
so you actually see much more compounds
here on the right side especially high
molecular weight and polar ones because
those have low energy constant and
therefore they are not extracted very
well
by headspace approach
so how do we now do that incorporate
this approach direct extraction and
clean
extraction so basically here
it is shown what we do
so we basically have the fiber as you
can see
another part of the slide
which is at the
the coating is surrounded by the
protection layer
okay and this protection layer as is
shown below can consist of the teflon
for example polychromonetrol or pdms
so if you have such a system
uh because of this protection layer
nothing is being absorbed on the surface
of this
foreigner
so you have a clean extraction so you
just need to hit rapid rings
uh and with clean water and perform the
adoption
now in addition
this technology works
very well from practical foundation
produces are called balanced coverage of
hydrophobic
and hydrophilic compounds at the same
time this means we can extract
compounds from different log p as long
as the
solvent has high enough polarity to go
very deep in the
uh
polar range
so basically why does it happen
so here this slide demonstrate that you
have x you have this
fibrous extraction phase
in addition around the fiber exists are
called boundary layers so
it is the static layer
this exists in any type of system placed
in a fluid
tissue
so the in order for the high molecules
to go through it takes long time so
within a half an hour or so or less when
we perform the
sampling or
blood extraction whatever
those do not typically use the fiber if
they reach it as i mentioned the fiber
is
surface is
impregnated with the polymer which
prevents its absorption so you balance
it you can get rid of
meanwhile small molecules
and those darker points are hydrophobic
ones so you can see they are heavily
bound to the matrix because of course
phytophobic analytes
free concentration is very long like
hydrophilic
as you can see very poorly bound so
three concentrations of almost equal to
the total concentration
and therefore as you put the fiber in
you immediately equilibrate with the
with the polar compounds and
slowly extract the hydrophobic ones
so within half an hour you collect both
very effectively
and here just to show you how does it
work so you compare the
[Music]
hydrophobic with hydrophilic you know
morphine
is a hydrophilic compound so you can see
there's no difference between extraction
of ptms plasma plasma contains a pro
protein that pds not
so so basically you can see the since i
mentioned the three equal total the
amount of extracted in both cases the
same
why in hydrophobic you can see huge
difference
there's no protein to extract more
because in that case three equal total
why in
when you have a protein some binding
occurs in there
but actually
by basing much lower concentrations
so this is as i mentioned due to the
binding if you want to consider this
process more fully you also need to
consider this dissociation rate constant
and so on which we have done as well if
you look at our recent publications
which is actually shown here
some very brief summary what this
publication is
turning about
uh is basically showing that because you
have this balance between the
competing extraction
by the matrix compared to the
partitioning onto the fiber
you actually
extract the same amount or close to the
same amount independent
of the log p of the compound until of
course the coating is not capable to
extract anymore this means if it's very
polar
you because you can
component very polar ionic would be not
extracted but have hydrophobic type of
extraction phase
even a very polar one
so basically
because of this competitive
binding we have this con con
so-called balance coverage and you can
extract
range of compounds very effectively
and we validated that for a number of
experiments here
some of those initial validations when
you look at the bacteria growth
uh and to and we extracted them
number of experiments you can see we
published in june of metabolomics what
does it mean is basically this tool is
very effective in extracting full range
of
polarity of the compound so you can
actually get
metabolomic metabolism profile
and the composition extractor from 100
to 1000 now we can do even more
depending on the porosity of this
protection layer i mentioned about
as you can see we detect some minus log
if you use a
solvent such as
hiv
you know the sorbent
we can detect it from um
look p minus seven to all the way to
fifteen
so we see all the compounds however
because we extracted the free form is a
very clean extraction
so if you compare for example our
approach spme which is upper trace
versus lower trace protein precipitation
you see you have a this is a fully this
is blank after 40 rounds of pruning
pre-precipitation and upper is blank
after 40 rounds of
spme
as you can see
below
we have huge
phospholipid band coming
why in other
or upper chromatogram which is basically
multiple background
of the chromatin below
so it's basically hundred times more
sensitive
um
the
description so it's basically you
multiply
the
background by hundred times and so you
see you have very very
low background here the spme doesn't
extract the huge amount of phospholipids
as putting precipitation as because
we don't dissolve the
phospholipids extracting their free form
but the solubility is so low so we
expect some of them to see them but not
enough to cause the trouble
okay so now from practical point of view
how do you use this technology so the
um one of the approach for high
throughput we are using this
device called concept 96 with 96 blade
system so instead of coating fibers
we're actually coating blades to
increase the surface area of the solar
bender and therefore increasing mass
transfer
to the extraction phase
and having as you can see four different
96 wall
plates one of it
we perform the
activation the other one
extraction then rinsing and then this
option and then this 96 wall plate is
unless dissolved into it it can go to
the unicorn instrument
now what advantages of this approach
versus the sp
so basically the major one is because
it's open back system
yeah so it's basically no
particles of the
t-shirt can be trapped there
one spe
when you percolate the sample through it
may occur so that reasons why as i
showed you before there is no matrix
effect
in this technology
you can do it also much
easier
automation
as shown here
and um
we can look at the
larger amount of samples
uh without worrying about breakthrough
so there are several advantages and this
is
well described in the literature
now more recently
uh there was an improvement this design
uh where you can see now there's a tower
which holds the 964 plate which i
exchanged one by one so first
one was used for activation and
exchanges for extractions and raisins
and desorption so such a device a little
bit less expensive so it's available
from company called ps technologies if
you're interested
now
the other beautiful feature of spme as i
mentioned in the beginning is because
you can sample directly from the source
is the excellent tool for in vivo
spme
and the primary reason for it is is
because you don't need to take a tissue
out so we call it chemical biopsy we
equilibrate the coating
with the
system
and then
you cut this and if you make this
coating in the form of coated fiber so
it could be very small you
show minimum damage and you don't take
any tissue out you just take chemistry
out
so babra will explore
give you this this approach further give
you some applications and again again
the beauty about it is
that
when you remove this chemistry out you
also isolate this chemistry from the
enzymes
and therefore
there's no enzymatic
degradation of the sample so you in fact
you're combining the extraction with
quenching automatically and there's no
matrix effects it's a very effective
tool
so in summary what's why it's in the
voice creamy is very important first of
all
it's a medium
coverage of the small molecules is very
good
eliminates
suppression in mass spectrometry
measurement
captures unstable one lines
that's because you equilibrate with real
system and you can analyze immediately
after the extraction and then finally
because you are
sampling the system with minimum damage
for example if you do
my studies you can use one mice or the
whole pharmacokinetic profile
without doing much damage to the mines
so this is
improve the precision because
inter-animal variability is eliminated
here's the example
so here one of the our first studies and
for those who are interested
you can look into the paper which is
listed below when we compare standard
approach on the right which is the
protein precipitation
you know standard approach
and
on the left you have the two
spme approaches one is equilibrium one
is pre-equally blue so short-term
sampling long-term 75-minute versus two
minutes
but you can see there is no difference
in the profile no difference even in
absolute values so there is no reason
to do it
direct
to do
traditional methods where you actually
need to draw
a lot of blood from animals
and you can also do tissue sampling so
we recently published this paper
chemistry there are a lot of attentions
you can see
and basically what it is as you can see
there are two devices principally which
we use in
uh in there
in the usp one
lower one you can see traditional one
where you have a fiber in the sheath
you know
the needle like i showed you before
and then
the upper part
where you actually have the
coated needle which when the coating is
in the
um
in the
recess
so
because now we can make this coating
very robust
so the tip
penetrates the tissue
there's not much much shear forces on
the coating so we can reuse this even
many times
so this is the
we think this would be the ideal medical
device and we are working with number of
surgeons
and
animal
persons involved researchers in both
animal studies
and finally what i wanted to say because
extraction is clean we don't need to
have chromatography we can go directly
to mass spectrometry
so this is really the idea
for moving it everything on site
especially if you want to move it close
to the surgery room or even doctor's
office so we can do it with extractions
devices in the form blades humans meshes
and fibers which already discussed
and again this has been discussed in
this review paper i mentioned to you and
i will not talk about in any more
details just indicate that this is an
opportunity
uh here i show you my group
but i will show you also
but i just wanted to show you what you
see about is my website
why indicate to you because we actually
have the courses twice a year
the next one would be december 6th and
7th
this year if you're interested you can
sign up to actually experience stme not
only in lectures but also in practice we
actually have a practical experiment
there
finally there's also a
conference called xtec
and next year is going to be in
guangzhou china so again you are very
much welcome
to attend it
if you found this technology and
interesting and if you are interested to
explore other extraction technologies so
now i give my
space to barbara to continue the
presentation
so hello everybody
now i will continue the talk by giving
you some more information about uh
clinical applications
and some other bioapplications like some
cell line studies
so basically
whatever janus was talking about
fits the clinical purpose so as as you
can see here
spme as you already know is used in
headspace mode also in direct immersion
mode
and it both applies to a clinical or
bioapplication so basically i will focus
on direct immersion
uh headspace is also used mainly for
example uh for breath analysis but also
other analysis
direct immersion is
more new because uh
we have right now biocompatible fibers
and thanks to that feature uh it allows
us to basically insert fiber directly
into the
tissue or or blood
so the workflow that janusz discussed
with you uh also applies here so as you
can see after extraction the fiber is
quickly rinsed and then it goes to uh
organic solvent or organic acute solvent
mixture
and then we basically inject this
extract to a chromatograph couples to
mass spectrometer in most of the cases
uh so we are using
uh
two basic devices two basic geometries
of spme
so fiber which is the
main geometry that we are using for
tissue analysis because we want to
provide minimum invasiveness to the
system
and then also so-called blades so this
is basically thin film
uh to improve the sensitivity
but also this is very common to be used
in high throughput mode and i will also
show you some examples uh of such
applications
uh so
here i just want to
show you what are the solutions of spme
to the demands that uh clinical
applications have
so first of course uh we need to have
very simple
uh method of sample collection ideally
we don't want to collect any sample if
you want to for example doing viva as
january explained it would be great we
don't want to deal with too much samples
so of course here we can either take
very small amounts of the sample very
small volumes because as you have
already seen the fiber can be really
small so the extraction
phase can be really very
very small
so you don't really need to have
a large volume of the sample
or as i mentioned if you have in vivo
type of application you don't collect
any sample you just extract small
molecules of or other molecules if your
extraction phase is designed for that
from the system and then you basically
do not take out any sample
so the second demand is a simple
analytical workflow so if we uh really
want to have spme or any other
technology in clinical lab it cannot be
very complex workflow we want to have
the least steps
possible and in fact spme is
very simple so of course it requires
optimization there is no magic here but
it integrates the sampling and sample
preparation in one step
and if we
also
want to have a metabolism quenching for
example if we are looking for biomarkers
we need to quench metabolism immediately
once we collect the sample and here
again if we do in vivo
then we have also quenching integrated
with two previous steps
so then
it would be nice if we don't have to
have for
different applications different methods
and i will show you a number of examples
here where we can use spme and pretty
much with the same workflow so we can
use the same technology uh for many
different applications we can do target
analysis which is the most common for
clinical
analysis but also we can do for example
a medical research based also towards
biomarkers discovery so we can do for
example
metabolome profiling or lipidomics
analysis
and
another demand from clinical point of
view
uh is a
application for complex mattresses
whatever we whatever matrix we deal with
so pretty much plasma urine
serum like whole blood or tissue uh
these are really complex mattresses uh
so as young mentioned and also i already
mentioned in in my part we have already
biocompatible
materials which we use for production of
the fibers
and basically we don't experience any
matrix effect later on we are
eliminating
large molecules from the system
and the
matrix components they do not attach to
the fiber
okay so another two things which are
necessary to be
fulfilling the lab is high throughput
and automation
and in fact as janus already
mentioned in his
part
we have the automated system that
basically covers all
steps in spme workflow which is
reconditioning
extraction wash desorption and also on
top of that we can do evaporation and
reconstitution
we also have an option to have a
semi-automated system so we are just
replacing the 96 uh well plates
but we still have full control on the
temperature
we have agitation of the system
and of course we have high throughput
and then we go and we have high
sensitivity and wide dynamic range
and of course uh it was already
mentioned we have variety of sorbents
and geometries you can play with so by
increasing for example
uh volume of the solvent
uh we have
the increased high
increased sensitivity so we have
basically this high sensitivity we are
dealing with low concentrations
and of course we can also play with the
time of our extraction so we can work at
the equilibrium if we want to really
reach
the highest possible concentration i
mean sensitivity or we can work at
pre-equilibrium so then we actually have
much shorter extraction time but we
sacrifice sensitivity
then a very important thing is to
sterilize the fiber or the whatever
device we are using or to use them just
a single time
and already from our experience we know
that
we may autoclave the fibers we can do
basically regular out of um we can do
regular sterilization with autoclaving
but we can also use for example
gas sterilization and of course alcohol
sterilization because in most of the
cases
the pre-conditioning is done in the
mixture of methanol water
we may want to also have a temporal and
special resolution
so for that we can of course use the
small fibers for example so we can have
number of sampling points just by
inserting the fibers at different time
points and we still have very low
invasiveness the
size of the fiber the dimension of the
fiber is approximately 10 times lower
than the acupuncture than the
biopsy needle so we can easily repeat
sampling of the same animal or of the
same
organ
number of times
of course in the same time we can
do number of extractions so for example
we can have the same
time point of extraction and we can have
simultaneous sampling of different areas
of the body
we can have fully quantitative method
and we don't have time today to play
with
calibration uh
and explain you all type of calibrations
we have but diana's already mentioned a
few
so
here we can really uh choose from a
variety of different calibration
approaches and we can
have fully quantitative data and i will
show example in a minute
uh of course we want to have results
very fast this is the first thing that
clinicians ask
how fast i can get the data well uh of
course if we are including um
sc run it usually uh a little bit long
but as janus mentioned we can couple
spme directly with ms and then we are
actually
hoping to have uh with desired copying
to have uh um instrumentation on site so
so give the data immediately after uh
sampling
and of course it's very important we
don't want to have very large organic
solvents on site we don't want to deal
with organic solvents if possible and
spme actually because this micro
extraction technology we basically have
very minimum consumption of organic
solvents and if we have direct cutting
with the mass it's actually even less
so now i will go through a few examples
of clinical applications the first one
is focus on oncology
so right now we are working on
phenotyping of brain tumors and we are
working towards intraoperative
monitoring of biomarkers
so basically there are two goals
first is to propose
a few compounds which differentiate
brain tumors and their grades so we are
mainly focused on gliomas
and the other one is to propose new fast
analytical approach to on-site
diagnostic testing of brain tumor so
that's what i already mentioned to
basically have very fast
um answer uh in the operating room
and here you can see how we do sampling
of tumors so these tumors were just
resected this is still in our room so we
are inserting several fibers to the
to the tumor on the left you can see
meningiomas and
on the right you can see glioma so
basically we choose uh
meningioma because this is um i would
say easy
uh two more to be sampled this uh
they resected usually
as the whole tumor and uh this is very
very easy to be recognized by
histological
testing so basically we were using this
tumor as a reference so we were
comparing our data with histology
on the right as i said you can see
glioma so this type of tumor has many
subtypes it's very malignant tumors so
this is the one that we are interesting
interested in to basically find
biomarkers of different grades of
gliomas and also subtypes of gliomas
which are susceptible for a given
treatment or not
on the next slide as you can see we were
optimizing the method for uh this brain
tumor so we were testing different
uh absorption solvents we have selected
seven millimeter uh coating for those
fibers because this is the optimum
size that basically fit our purpose
and
then we were running the extracts using
lcms but high resolution mass spec
you can see in the middle figures how
many features we were able to actually
extract
so you can see that even with just seven
millimeter fiber and half an hour
sampling we've been able to
obtain to extract
hundreds of uh
hundreds of compounds uh and we always
run in helix mode and uh reverse phase
mode just to increase the coverage of
analytes so as you can see here we are
basically covering on each column from
about hundred to few hundred
compounds
then you can see that we were very
successful in differentiating two
different types of tumors so basically
gliomas remaining giomas i don't have
time to show you more data today but we
were also able to differentiate
different grades of tumors and also
when we compared with histological and
genotyping data
our phenotyping we're actually in very
good agreement on the right you can see
that we are able to actually pick up
compounds of interest so compounds which
of course after
running a larger cohort and
after
going through proper
validation we can actually propose some
potential biomarker
for different tumor types and different
um different uh malignancy grades so
right now we are also focusing on
lipidomics because we want to uh extend
our studies to lipidomic data and right
now we are already looking into the data
from more than 200 patients
uh another oncological project that we
are involved it's actually in
collaboration with toronto general
hospital as a monitoring of
dr rubin this is the drug which was used
for high dose local chemotherapy so
basically
that was
animal study so as you can see here that
was big model
our
collaborators the clinicians they were
actually
looking into the
concentration and distribution of this
drug
in the lung so different lobes of the
lung because they are working on new
methods um
of drug delivery so basically they were
using the perfusion system to deliver
this particular chemotherapeutic agents
to the lung tissue
where
the tumor is located so basically the
lungs are isolated from the rest of the
body so the chemotherapeutic agent
shouldn't actually go
into different parts of the body
uh so the problem that the clinicians
had was basically how what is the
concentration uh of the drug because uh
they cannot do
uh that many biopsies uh over the period
of this perfusion so we were basically
inserting the fiber
uh to the lung
as you can see here
and uh the arrow points actually into
three fibers located in one of the lobes
of the lung and so this is on the left
side of the picture and on the right you
can see exactly the same spot after
sampling so as you can see actually the
the
method is not really invasive there is
no bleeding there are just
air bubbles coming up
but
basically we were we were repeating the
same procedure number of times so you
will see the results in a moment of
course again this is the targeted method
it requires optimization
so we were looking into the effect of
autoclaving
uh so basically autoclaving even
improved the effectiveness of the
extraction we are also testing different
uh preconditioning solvents and uh what
is very important
we of course here need to do calibration
so as i mentioned we will not go into
details but uh here i just mentioned
where we were using external calibration
so as a surrogate matrix
we were using a lump lung
and we homogenized this matrix and
basically we were spiking at different
concentrations of the doxorubicin and we
were extracting exactly using the same
extraction time
and as you can see on the bottom right
picture we were comparing the results
from the tissue collected in the
hospital so first we were extracting
from this intact tissue and then we
homogenized the same tissue and we
extract from this homogenate and we were
getting exactly the same data
using the calibration curve prepared in
this rogate matrix
so then
this method of course we're fully
validated so you can see the results we
meet all the
uh requirements and then you can see
basically the results uh during the
perfusion how the concentration and
distribution
of the uh drug was changing so the
clinicians were using two different
those of the drug you can see first it
was increasing then at some point the
drug concentration was dropping so as
you can see we can get fully
quantitative data
uh using in bingo extraction
and for calibration using
external
calibration curve
of course
in vivo solid phase micro extraction was
used for many other studies here you can
see how we are doing extraction uh from
the circulatory system from from the
blood system you can use either this
needle assembly fibers so you can insert
them directly to the vein of the animal
and then
expose the fiber to the bloodstream for
the extraction
or you can also place this fiber through
the
catheter which is standard for
clinical
application you can also insert the
non-assembly fiber through the
lower lock type of designs and so it's
very flexible method as you can see you
can just adjust it to your needs so
basically you can tailor your method uh
to your needs and to the environment you
need to work with
in terms of rodent studies of course
such fiber especially assembly fiber is
too big to be inserted directly to the
vein of the animal
so in that case you basically use one of
the interfaces that was developed for
that purpose so here you can see that
there are basically different designs
one which is in the middle this is uh
basically the interface which is like a
loop so one end is inserted into one
vein of the animal and then the other
end
it goes back to the animals so the blood
circulates through this interface so you
can basically insert the fiber
uh to this interface and you can also
use for example syringe or other pump
to provide some agitation by using a
push-pull type of
agitation
and then on the right you can see that
also this type of device can be one way
so again you can use the push-pull with
syringe for example to agitate the blood
through the device and then you can
sample as it is as shown on the picture
so again some examples
of the applications so exactly these
devices were used for
extraction from the bloodstream of
carbamazepine and its metabolites so
basically the colleague of mine was
using full pharmacokinetic profiling
pharmacokinetic
profile of carbamazepine and its
metabolite
and it was the spme data was compared
with automated serial
sampling and also terminal blood draw
so
for those of you who are not familiar
with the technologies basically for this
kind of studies
pharmacokinetic analysis you really need
to use number of animals so you either
sacrifice one animal per data point
that's for the terminal
and or you can basically take a volume
of blood and then the animal needs to
recover for some time to be used for
next sampling so as you can see here
uh basically the number of animals needs
to be
quite large to get this full
pharmacokinetic profile as shown on the
picture
and if you look carefully into the data
spme and gives the same
results but rsd is actually
a lot lower for spme because as janus
already mentioned we are actually
eliminating inter-animal variability
here so first we don't sacrifice that
many animals and the other one we are
improving the data by
eliminating inter-animal or minimizing
animal variability
we are not limited to blood on that
picture you can see that we are also
using uh pharmacokinetic profiling of
carbamazepine
but from the right brain
and for this type of studies we are also
using micro dialysis
for comparison because this is
basically a gold standard i would say
for
brain studies and as you can see again
the data was in full agreement between
the two methods
uh we are not limited to drugs
absolutely we can also do endogenous
compounds so this is the
uh example of the
targeted metabolomic so as you can see
here
uh a colleague of mine he was actually
looking into different neurotransmitters
during drug stimulation
so
again
comparison of micro dialysis
showed a very good agreement but in fact
he was interested in four
neurotransmitters
but
because of low sensitivity of micro
dialysis
we were only uh seeing we only seen uh
two neurotransmitters with micro
dialysis but spme allowed us to see
uh all four of them but uh despite the
fact that we have seen two again you can
see that the data is in full agreement
between the two methods
and uh while we already had the um
and the extract from from the targeted
analysis uh we we thought that it would
be good to actually check
uh how the interrelated metabolomics
look like when we compare spme and
microdialysis and as you can see from
that table and the graph there was
number of compounds that actually
changed over the time after the drug
stimulation
and of course there was a huge uh
difference between microdialysis and
spme in terms of coverage because
microdialysis
is basically the method used for polar
compounds so non-polar compounds are not
going to the dialysate
but for spme actually
we had much better uh coverage for
for non-polar compounds and uh slightly
uh less for the polar compounds
comparing to micro dialysis so basically
these two methods can be nicely used
together giving us a very uh very broad
coverage of
analytes
and then i will go to the next uh
project that
we have done now i as you can see
we were using this high throughput and
automated system so basically we were
looking into the
uh first pharmacokinetic of two drugs
tranexamic acid and or coronium bromide
in the patients who received a liver
graft and we had two groups first was
heartbeating donors and the other one
living donors so basically uh especially
for rocuronium uh we were checking if
this drug can be used and marker of
early graph dysfunction because the
dead donors so basically heartbeating
donor groups are supposed to have
worst metabolism of the drug because the
drug is mainly metabolized by liver and
in fact we were
we were right so basically this drug can
be potentially used as a marker
of early liver dysfunction
but we also looked into the global
profile of the patient so we were using
exactly the same system for doing
targeted and untargeted analysis because
for this type of
of analysis you need to have really um
quite a large group so we just for this
and targeted profiling we just took a
part of the patient's samples and we
just check if we have any type of
separation as you can see here we were
able to differentiate between the two
groups and also
pick up some compounds which
differentiate the group so of course
after again running a larger cohort
if we confirm those compounds can be
potentially used as biomarkers of early
liver dysfunction
when we are talking about high
throughput system especially 96
96
plates well placed
we can also think about different in
vitro essays related to
cell culturing
so here also we are using this system
that i showed you previously the fully
automated system and also
a semi-automated system for doing a cell
line analysis well usually we culture
cell lines or doing any type of for
example
microsome
essays in 96 well forma
and this is also fully compatible with
the device that we showed you previously
so here for example you can see that we
can use this 96 well plates for
capturing the cells and then doing time
course analysis so basically uh
using the same
samples
uh for number of times for extraction of
number of times and then we can get a
time course analysis so we can observe
what compounds are declining and what
compounds are appearing in the system so
for example here we were observing the
effect of drug first we were extracting
from just from the cancer cells and then
we exposed them to the drug and we were
observing changes over the period of
time exactly from the same wells
uh the standard methods
for the standard methods you basically
need to stop metabolism and you cannot
reuse the same sample you need to
basically have number of uh samples for
the experiments if you want to look over
the period of time here we can decrease
number of samples and reuse the same
samples for uh different
time point analysis
uh also this 96 well format as i
mentioned it used for for example
microsome analysis so here we were
looking into the
metabolism of the drug umbreta statin
which is fairly new drug and so far
there is just a few metabolites known so
we've been using this time course
analysis with spme
to figure out what compounds what new
compounds are coming
up when we basically incubate drug with
the microsomes we compare this data with
electrochemical metabolism detection and
then we verify it within silicon
prediction
and as you can see uh we've been able to
increase the number of uh metabolites
from 5 to 16 with the proposed
approach
so basically to sum up you can see that
spm is very flexible technology it can
be used in a high throughput mode and it
can be used in
just the fiber
mode to
have very low invasive sampling so you
can easily sample a very complex
mattresses including tissues you can get
very nice and broad analyte coverage
the method is very minimum invasive you
if you use just this tiny fiber which is
basically the acupuncture needle size
then you can have the time course
analysis
if you want to perform
some extraction from either for example
tissue without damaging the system or
for example you may minimize the number
of samples and still have a full um
full idea about the changes over the
period of time
method is fully quantitative
so as i said
there is number of
calibration methods that you can use for
that
and uh you can especially use them for
different clinical but also medical
research type of application
in i prefer actually this this method
for tissue analysis over the
uh over the uh traditional method
because we are actually having here
a
true snapshot of the metabolism when we
do in vivo studies versus
homogenized studies
you can do
cell culturing
with your traditional 96 plate system
anatomy dual plate system and you can
basically reuse the same sample and even
at the end you can perform traditional
essays on the same samples
and of course if we
couple spme directly with mass spec or
other
instrumentation we can provide
our clinicians with intraoperative rapid
diagnostic tool in the near future
and i also want to acknowledge uh all my
students also janus group of course our
collaborators
and our sponsors
uh who are providing us with the
instrumentation
and uh the skme devices thank you very
much for your attention
thank you
thank you dr boiko and dr pavlisian for
that informative presentation we will
now start the q a portion of the webinar
and we'll address some of the most
commonly asked questions by our viewers
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
ask a question drop down box located on
the far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button
our speakers will follow up with your
questions via email so let's get started
the first question is
why did solid phase micro extraction
technology not find its way to general
use in clinical laboratories yet
okay so maybe i will take it
uh
i think that there is not too many
[Music]
groups that are using the technology
it's
fairly new in bioapplications
but basically we can see that for the
last
four or five years the interest is
really growing so clinicians are
really happy with the technology so we
basically work with
many groups
especially surgeons but not only
but i think that well
right now there is the only
um
one
uh one company which provides the
biocompatible fibers so that may be one
of the of the problems
but i think that also people are
they do not treat sample preparation
as a science so uh
they are very focused especially in
medical
area they're very much focused on the
traditional methods so uh i think that
that this is one of the problems that uh
basically the medical area is is very
difficult to go through with some new
things and spma is definitely one of
such things
but i can see from our experience that
actually more and more people is
interested so i hope that in the near
future it will be much more people
many many people are using that much
more than today
thank you for that next one is what is
the future of the spme
technology yes
basically
the spme
is a very simple way of performing
sample preparation
the future is bright
the issue is it's a new kick on the
block
so
in fact it's kind of related to the
previous question
anything which new looks very difficult
now because the device looks different
the procedure is a little different
calibrations are not different but
they are somewhat different in some
cases
so
there's a lot of reservation
however the format is so simple
that it can actually potentially solve a
lot of problems for example just to give
you the idea
one of the future i see for the
technology and i mentioned that this
picture of the drone
is that actually you can connect
patients
environmental pollution
even in remote places
into the center labs
and so so basically
the devices are so light
because they actually enrich the center
in a small volume like small fiber or
some blades do you also use the measures
of the performance you can then easily
transport it certainly
therefore remove communities for example
not in canada africa as you know the
issues of providing the services for
those communities could be very easy
very easy reached by those technologies
so this is definitely one of the future
in addition of course the whole lecture
we'll see is the future
because not many labs are using it
thank you for that next one is is
saturation of the coding a problem
yes i
mentioned that in my part of my
presentation that
because we have this
process of extraction vr
reform
and three form of analytes is controlled
by the solubility of analytes
and the compounds which are hydrophobic
which actually has a poor solubility in
aqueous matrix which is most of the
number cause it constitutes
basically
limits this possibility of saturation
when i talk to a lot of
scientists because of the paradigm
that's what i'm saying you need to think
outside the box this was the first
picture i showed because they always
think such a small device that someone
has a coupon they can do so much damage
to them but in fact they don't
and in fact
if they did will die
because a lot of systems works in very
similar way
you know the proteins which carry the
analytes are not saturated by other
analytes because the quality are
prevented to do that
so
basically in the same fight the fiber
cooling breeze was a system but because
the calibration occurs vr free from
liquid media
the
saturation is occurs because the
compounds which can saturate hydrophobic
on the lines are not very soluble so the
process of extraction extremely slow so
with the material time which would
perform the distraction is not enough
analytes using the fiber to saturate
thank you looks like we have time for
just one more question
how is solid phase micro extraction
calibrated
yeah so this is as i mentioned one of
the standing block because instead
people say well how do you calibrate the
process which is completely different
exhausted extraction an exhaustive
extraction kind of break on volume so
you take one liter of water or one
millimeter of blood and then whatever
you extract it from just one liter or
one milliliter
and you divide by the volume gives you
the concentration here it's a little bit
different
so basically you need to
develop a calibration profile called
matrix match calibration which is
basically the same things what we are
doing in an exhaustive network because
the issue is if you have a complex
matrix you still validate that you have
exhaustive extraction just by using the
calibrations
of the analytes and so on but the same
theory
the same thing here you can use the
literally analog
to calibrate
basically in a sense find the k value
of some other parameter
and based on that you can calibrate your
underlines because if you know the key
value you will even make things you can
do that
there's also a very interesting way of
calibrating code called
calibrate in the extraction field
because
remember it's not exhaustive techniques
when you place the fiber
in the coating in the
temple actually the analytes can also
lead or the vibrance can leave the
talking to go to the media because
there's multiface
so in that case you actually can
calibrate for the convection compression
right because when you have done
extraction phase in contact with the
matrix the amount of index is extracted
depending on the conventional conditions
and the concentration so you can ratio
those convection functions as i said
so in a sense they are very similar
calibration approaches at the
traditional method